I think it's fair
to say
you are best known to most audiences
for having played
Wolverine in the X-Men movies.
And here we have a clip of you fighting,
and it doesn't actually go so well.
Mistake.
Oh, yeah, right.
Right.
So there are a couple of things
that come out of this
that I want to ask you about.
One is
Wolverine is five foot five, right?
You are six foot two right.
So how on earth
did you get yourself cast for this role?
I did about seven auditions.
Am I wired in completely?
I want to do a little like
I remember
finally I did
audition, audition, audition,
and then I went to see
they had a production.
We were talking and he said, you know,
it's just one problem.
I hope
the fans are not going to have a problem
because the carrot
is meant to be five foot five.
And I said, Tom,
really, it's going to be absolutely fine.
Don't worry about it. Thank you.
I literally walked out like that.
And actually, in the first movie,
Chris yes.
I never had my shoes on.
Every other actor around me.
The rule was, unless I were a kid,
they had to be taller.
Me people were on
I was literally crouching like that.
Shoes off.
People were on
planks and boxers all around me.
So we went to a great effort.
And I think
after a while, they just gave up on that.
Okay, second question.
How did you learn to deal with those
claws?
You know,
we were just
watching that clip, Chris,
and you know what came into my head
in that fight?
I actually stabbed the double of mistake
like so in the beginning, there were
I don't know what we were thinking.
There were actually metal
and they were actually sharp.
And I used to practice
I practice at home and looked at because
I'd done a lot of fighting. Right.
But never with another.
I had to get used to another nine inches
all my hand as I'm fighting.
So I had to adjust
how I practice practice.
And I would follow through.
I stab my thighs.
I had like scars.
I still have scars on my thighs.
And in that particular scene,
there's one thing
where she's reaching for something,
and I go to stab her arm.
She forgot to move her arm.
And I literally stepped
it went about this deep into her arm.
And I'll never forget it.
She I was
I went wide
I've literally just stab someone
for the first time in my life.
And she just
the blood was burbling out like
it was
starting to come and she just like this.
And she goes,
I've been stabbed by Wolverine.
There was a just blue and red.
It was pouring down around it
because she was a stuntwoman
and she's a hell of a lot
tougher than me.
And it was a badge of honor for her.
You got so jacked for these movies,
nine Wolverine
movies, and over
the years, people have wondered,
did he Juice did he take steroids?
No, I, I love my job
and I love Wolverine.
I'm going to be careful what I say here.
But I had been told anecdotally
what the side effects are of that,
and I was like,
I don't love it that much.
Yeah. No, no, no. I
so no, I just did it the old school way.
And I tell you, I've eaten more chicken.
So I'm so sorry to all the vegans
and vegetarians
and to the chickens of the world.
I mean, I've,
I've just I've literally I'm
the calm is not good for me.
If if if the diet has anything related
to chickens, I'm in trouble.
Finally,
I understand that you're set to play
in the next Deadpool movie.
And even though your character Logan
or Wolverine was killed off
in the last movie,
you're going to play Wolverine again
for the 10th time.
Yeah. Why?
I mean, you categorize it
as the Deadpool movie.
We like to call it Wolverine ten
in our house.
And you check with Ryan Reynolds on this.
I need to check with then I'll get it.
We basically this is taking place.
The story's pre Logan,
which is
exactly, as you said, where Logan died.
So we pray that in the storyline
and I honestly, Chris,
I really thought I was done
like I was at peace with it.
If I got asked every day
that interviews or Ryan Reynolds ring,
you make me do it again.
I'm like, no, I'm done.
Someone said to me, I think it was
I think it was Deb and he was my wife.
She said, you know, after this,
what is it you really want to do?
And I was just driving down a day
later and I thought, what do I want?
And it came to me like that
because when I keep thinking of me
and Ryan of Deadpool
and Wolverine,
which are classic comic book rivals,
there's also a dynamic
that I've never really
got to do before as Wolverine.
But the music man is not Wolverine.
And with all due respect,
and after this interview, affection
Hugh Jackman at 54 is not Hugh
Jackman at 32.
So how are you going
to get in that kind of shape?
I have I've learned you can't rush it.
I've learned that it takes time.
So we have six months
from when I finish to
when I start filming.
And I'm not doing any other work.
I'm going to be with my family and train.
That's going to be my job for six months
and I'm really fit right now.
There's one thing that I chose
a wig being on Broadway, singing,
dancing is unfit.
So I'm healthy.
I've a good place to start.
And apologies, chickens run a mile.
Start running now
because I'm coming for you.